marcher sur la lune il a marché sur la
cible
2 avril bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
want is cette
géniale et précis alors buzz aldrin vous
êtes présents à paris dans le cadre du
12e festival du film jules verne dont le
président est james cameron c'est du 9
au 16 mars au grand rex un jury
décernera le jules verne award du
meilleur documentaire et le 11 mars il
ya une nuits thématiques nuit du ciel et
de l'espace où vous étiez l'invité
spécial le grand sujet de cette nuit du
11 mars c'était la planète mars est ce
que vous croyez buzz aldrin qu'on peut
se baigner sur mars
je ne pense pas qu'on puisse s'y baigner
la classe au pool de 20
en dessous du sol peut-être mais
certainement pas de cette façon-là
dommage dans tous les cas vous pensez
qu'il faut aller sur mars et vous êtes
persuadé qu'un jour l'homme se
dispersera sur les différentes planètes
éclatèrent restera la planète de la
génèse
je crois que les êtres humains doivent à
un stade de à venir dans l'avenir
devront s'établit
aller habiter en dehors de la terre
de manière à ce que si un jour la terre
devaient être ramenés être détruite
qu'il y ait une possibilité de survie de
notre civilisation et nous avons cette
responsabilité là à l'égard des
générations à venir
alors voilà c'est très impressionnant de
vous recevoir buzz aldrin vous êtes vous
est pour nous un vrai héros vous êtes le
vétéran du premier alunissage en 1969 la
mission apollo 11 c'est un petit peu un
héros comme dans les légendes antiques y
avait les ulis les héros de homer vous
dites les minutes les plus exaltantes de
ma mission furent la descente en modules
vers la lune parce que à ce moment là
quand quand vous quittez le vaisseau
spatial et que le module lem descend
vers la lune à un moment il ya une panne
d'ordinateur je crois non
heureusement l'ordinateur haüy panne
complète simplement il y avait une
légère surcharge
et nous avions du mal à avoir nos
affichage anormaux donc c'est vrai que
c'est un petit peu distrait notre
attention
mais un contrôleur à houston très
intelligemment a compris où était le
problème est très rapidement il nous a
dit tout va bien vous pouvez y aller il
était acceptable que nous y avions que
nous à l'unission c'est vrai que ça a
duré un peu plus longtemps que prévu on
était un petit peu à l'écart il nous
manquait un peu de carburant oui c'était
juste nous n'avions que plus que ce 15
secondes de carburant fera dix ans
extraordinaire quand disons à l'unil
leur restait 15 secondes de carburant et
c'est neil amstrong qui est qui qui a
pris les commandes et qui a posé le lem
le module lunaire dans un endroit qui
n'était pas celui qui était qui était
prévu c'est sept km de là voilà alors
tout se passe bien et neil armstrong le
capitaine de la mission demande
d'avancer la sortie sur la lune ça s'est
tellement bien passé qui sont sorties
plus tôt et quand il évidemment on pose
le pied sur le sol lunaire il a cette
phrase qui restera pour l'éternité
graver un petit pas pour l'homme un bond
de géant pour l'humanité
c'est excellent ça c'est un slogan qui a
été trouvé par une agence de de madison
avenue sein
des conseils auprès de quelqu'un d'autre
mais je sais que personnellement en tout
cas j'aurai on déconseille à quelqu'un
d'autre s'ils savaient bien et c'est moi
qui avais dû le faire
16 juillet 1969 une grande date dans
l'histoire de l'humanité trois hommes
viennent de monter à bord du vaisseau
spatial apollo 11
objectif lune
le 19 juillet le vaisseau spatial entre
en orbite lunaire jusque là tout a été
répété lors des précédentes missions
mais à partir de maintenant pour apollo
11 c'est l'inconnu
[Musique]
hop
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
trois jours plus tard apollo 11 est de
retour dans l'atmosphère la capsule
fonce vers la terre à une vitesse de 40
mille kilomètres heure
la capsule apollo 11 flottent à la
surface du pacifique
enfin d'une mission qui a duré 195
heures 18 minutes et 35 secondes
en exauçant le voeu de kennedy d'envoyer
un homme sur la lune la nasa et les
astronautes avaient fait l'impensable
voilà
ça y est et hélas
il était avec lui ce soir il a marché
sur la lune
bon
alors
le le premier
le wii ware chiot oui c'est le premier
qui descend c'est neil armstrong et
quand vous le rejoignez quelques
quelques instants plus tard sur le sol
lunaire votre première remarque c'est de
dire c'est une magnifique désolation
c'est pas du tout un endroit où on
aimerait rester là l'une assez pas
sympathique ya pas un bistrot
tout est gris vous dit tout est gris
c'est que des différents gris
c'est la plus belle phrase il m'est venu
à l'esprit pour expliquer ces extrêmes
c'est-à-dire cet accomplissement
incroyable cet exploit et puis le côté
désolé parce qu'il n'y avait aucune vie
simplement différentes nuances de gris
la seule couleur qu'on voyait c'était la
couleur que nous avions avec nous alors
vous dites vue de la lune la terre
apparaît quatre fois plus grande mais
nous semblait loi est pourtant un
milliard de spectateurs vous regarde ce
soir-là et rigolent quand vous marchez
comme un comme un kangourou ni deux le
monde entier avait les yeux rivés sur
nous mais le rêve était sur la terre sur
la lune il n'y avait confié t ai
conscience de la charge c'est à dire ce
que vous dites en fait c'est que le plus
important dans toute cette histoire
c'est pas les cailloux qui ont été
connectés sur la lune le plus important
pour vous
c'est l'expérience personnelle vécue par
tous les terriens
tout à fait ce sont les genres est resté
sur terre qui ont eu le plaisir de ce
succès et qu'ils ont c'est vrai avec
nous et nous qui étions très intéressé
par le succès c'est vrai qu'on avait
beaucoup à faire
on n'a pas vraiment partagé cette
célébration ça nous est passé à côté oui
c'est vrai que tout le monde se souvient
de ce qu'il faisait ce jour-là dire que
tout le monde sur la terre qu'ils
étaient vivants à ce moment là dit
j'étais à tel endroit avec telle
personne c'est un moment qui a fédéré
toute l'humanité ce extraordinaire
je crois que moi aussi je m'en
souviendrai pour les jeunes
la frustration de celui qui reste dans
la cabine qui fait partie de l'équipe et
qui nient troisième il n'est pas
descendu les wayana qui n'est pas
descendu oui bah oui et l'huile est
arrivé deuxième alors c'est bien deux
prochaines grandes que j'aime bien non
mais c'est vrai que cette convergence
comme ça sur vous à ce moment là cette
nuit là donnent à ce voyage une
dimension spirituelle
extraordinaire bien au delà de l'exploit
technique d'une certaine façon c'est
vrai c'est vous qui avez dit ça mais
vous avez raison
j'avais le sentiment
qu'il fallait exprimé les remerciements
pour le succès de cette année ni sage
et sans le dire à d'autres cette époque
là c'est vrai que je me suis servi j'ai
fait que la communion vous savez avec
une aussi oui oui bien sûr vous avez
emporté dans le module lunaire un mini
accessoires de communion c'est à dire un
calice et une hostie un signe
ostentatoire voilà un signe ostentatoire
et une fois sur la lune vous communier
après avoir demandé une minute de
silence à la base de houston et pourtant
votre ardeur religieuse de l'époque donc
mais pas sortis renforcés mais plutôt
diminué par ce voyage
je crois que c'est vrai que la réflexion
a été amené à maturité
j'ai vu les choses
façon plus large je crois que mes
opinions sur la religion la spiritualité
et sont nettement plus large elle
englobe toute l'humanité plus que par le
passé je ne me concentre plus sur une
religion ou une secte donné c'est bien
donc ceci étant au retour buzz aldrin
vous avez un certain nombre de problèmes
des malaises une dépression traitement
psychologique et puis aussi l'alcoolisme
et et vous dites ça a été plus dur de
sortir de l'alcool que d'aller sur la
lune
probablement ce que j'ai vécu de plus
difficile
mais récemment j'ai fêté les 25 ans de
ma sobriété
ça s'arrose ouais
scott
buzz est ce qu'il y à un moune blues est
ce que il paraît que les douze personnes
qui ont marché sur la lune ont eu des
dépressions oui est ce que c'est ça est
ce que c'est parce qu'une fois qu'on est
allé sur la lune on sait plus quoi faire
sur la terre finalement
je sais très bien ce que je dois faire
j'essaye d'améliorer le programme
spatial et d'en aider d'autres à aller
dans l'espace à retourner sur la lune et
au bout du compte
amener des êtres humains aller sur mars
alors buzz aldrin ans a raconté que
durant ce voyage vous auriez vu des
choses que la nasa vous aurez interdit
de révéler à votre retour est-ce que
vous avez vu des petits hommes verts ou
des trucs extraordinaires que vous dont
vous auriez pas le droit de parler
certainement pas mais il ya une chose
qu'on a découvert quand même depuis
votre voyage c'est en 1999 quand il ya
eu les 30 ans du voyage sur la lune on a
découvert dans les archives du
gouvernement américain que si l époque
qu'il y avait eu un problème si vous
n'aviez pas été capable de remonter
depuis la lune jusque dans le vaisseau
spatial si le lem n'était pas arrivé a
redécollé le lem c'est un petit peu le
maillon faible de l'opération la nasa
avait décidé à ce moment là de couper
les communications et on vous aurait
laissé mourir sur la lune sans vous voir
et vous entendre
mais c'est quelque chose que à laquelle
je m'attendais au moment où s'est révélé
au public évidemment le public at il là
ils ont pensé à ça ils ont pensé que
vous pourriez mourir dont qui couperait
les communications et puis le président
évidemment il y avait préparé un
discours qui devait dire en cas d'échec
vous avez eu peur là-haut sérieusement
quand vous étiez là ou là sur la lune
vous avez eu peur
à bois de quoi
encore et j'ai descendu deux avions
ce que ça dure que ça ça vous donne une
préoccupation pour conclure deux aldrin
qu'est ce que ça vous a apporté cette
histoire qu'est ce que vous avez appris
dans toute cette histoire
what did you know
j'ai appris
que lorsque notre pays décide de faire
quelque chose on réagit ont répondu avec
force
et je crois que la raison pour laquelle
nous sommes allés sur la lune c'était de
battre les russes
parce que le monde était menacée par le
communisme soviétique et leur armement
nucléaire
et je crois qu'ils se sont rendus compte
au moment où nous sommes allés sur la
lune avant eux
qu'ils n'allaient pas pouvoir continuer
comme ça
les choses commençaient
l'union soviétique commençait à faiblir
à ce moment là puis plus tard lorsque
notre président a lancé un défi à la
russie dans le domaine de la défense les
systèmes de défense en utilisant
l'espace
la russie s'est aperçue qu'elle ne
pouvait tout simplement pas être à la
hauteur mais tout cela remonte à
l'époque où nous sommes arrivés sur la
lune des premiers essais des éléments
les plus importants d'une certaine
manière la paix dans le monde
aujourd'hui elle est liée au fait que
nous sommes allés sur la lune buzz
aldrin est ce que vous préférez les
américains quand ils vont sur la ligne
quand ils envahissent l'irak
je suis fier
que soient les soins fait
dirigeants je crois qu'ils comprennent
la situation qui prévaut dans le monde
et ils savent ce qu'il faut faire nous
voulons la paix dans le monde nous
sommes allés sur la lune dans un esprit
de paix pour l'humanité toute entière
nous sommes allés en irak dans un esprit
de paix pour l'humanité tout entière je
vais pas discuter avec vous non parce
qu'elle a marché sur la lune exactement
thank you very much
invité d'honneur du 12e festival jules
verne du 9 au 16 mars au grand rex merci
thank you very much chaque année
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu